une entrée en vigueur aujourd'hui dupas
sanitaire en tunisie la non présentation
d'une passe pourra entraîner des
sanctions dans la fonction publique un
décret jugée liberticide par les
opposants au pass vaccinale et certaines
organisations internationales lé
précision avec notre correspondant sur
place bassam chipie c'est un document
polémique qui fait sa grande entrée dès
aujourd'hui sur l'ensemble du territoire
tunisien le pass vaccinale dorénavant
obligatoire sera acclamé à chaque
personne de nationalité tunisienne où
résident en tunisie âgées de plus de 18
ans notamment dans les administrations
les établissements publics et privés
éducatif universitaires ainsi que les
espaces réservés aux activités de
loisirs culturelles sportives et les
lieux de culte objectifs du gouvernement
accélérer la campagne de vaccination et
limiter la propagation du comice 19 dans
un pays où la situation est stable
depuis quelques mois après un été
particulièrement meurtrier et les
autorités ont annoncé que le non respect
de ce décret loi rendant obligatoire le
pass sanitaire entraînera la suspension
de l'exercice de fonctions pour les
personnels de l'état des collectivités
locales des entreprises des
établissements publics ainsi que le
contrat de travail pour les salariés du
secteur privé et ce jusqu'à présentation
du pass vaccinale une décision
gouvernementale qui ne fait pas
l'unanimité dans le pays hier des
dizaines d'opposants s'étaient
rassemblés devant le parvis du tribunal
administratif pour dénoncer un document
liberticide et appelé le gouvernement à
revenir sur cette décision de son côté
amnesty international a condamné hier
ces mesures les jugeant abusives est
contraire au droit international écouter
les autorités tunisiennes doivent
introduire que des restrictions
nécessaires et proportionnées à la
protection de la santé publique
les dispositions de ce texte menace
inutilement les moyens de subsistance
des tunisiens en leur infligeant des
sanctions excessivement sévères en cas
de non respect cette exigence n'est
manifestement pas une restriction
légitime à la liberté de circulation en
vertu du droit international car elle
est injustifiée et injustement
restrictive alors que de nombreux
tunisiens se sont rués hier sur le site
du ministère de la santé pour obtenir le
précieux sésame de nombreux
restaurateurs et professionnels du
tourisme ont déclaré ne pas savoir s'il
allait imposer ou non le pass vaccinale
à leur clientèle